mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
heute geht es bei uns und körperliche
lust und um weibliche selbstermächtigung
die bretter
[Musik]
bovo gern sex hat nicht so ernst oder
offen ausspricht
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz wir sind
hier im zürcher kreis 4 und ich bin auf
dem weg zu thalia schmid die künstlerin
beschäftigt sich schon seit mehr als
zehn jahren mit den themen sexualität
und pornographie paula schmid bringt
menschen im museum dazu sich selbst zu
berühren sie kreiert leuchtend schöne
teppiche in form einer vulva sie hat das
filmfestival pony days mitbegründet und
sie leitet gruppen masturbation an
diese gruppen masturbation findet jetzt
erstmals per radio stadtbewohner sei
dank und zwar heute abend da sind wir
gerne mit dabei
[Musik]
warum
wir haben wir im studio vg dsf
der jordan wurde wonach twitter sound so
performance und tanz performance macht
sei mit denen die nachts arbeiten
studieren können wir sagen ja geld
dennoch ist speziell finden was er wird
dass man auch es verstanden hat die
performance schon mehrmals gemacht und
durch spielt vor live publikum wie
stoffs in grundidee ist das mit uns
machen also in der zeit vor der
digitalisierung und
internationalisierung
wo so viel interaktion vor dem
bildschirm stattfindet und jetzt geh
noch verstärkt durch die aktuelle krise
und die minigun social media und
kommunikations apps wo wir so die
physische begegnungen teil ist ablösen
kreieren wohl ab und und bewegt und
schmeckt und wo berichtet toxisch ist ja
und dann haben wir
die lüthi glatte in einen
ausstellungsraum helmes ist dass sie und
diese mit verbundenen augen geführt
wurde man zum abda mit einer abstand
alle gleich und sie haben während die
ganze performance nicht gewusst wären ab
ihnen liegt und über mit macht und wenn
ja wer das ist aber das muss man auch
etwas was ich dann kunst am ausprobieren
ich glaube das ganze drum dass wir es so
interessiert dass wir so bissig wo man
voser hat vor unserer gesellschaft oft
behandelt wird das mit günther sowie
waren sexualität und pornographie nötig
häuser kulturen das ist eine paradoxie
also zum beispiel antike ganz viel
wandmalerei und wasser malerei aus sehr
explizit sie sind wie seite
geschichtsbücher abbildet werdet also
die explizite darstellungen und das ist
irgendwie dass es mich interessiert hat
ja schon mehrere sexuelle revolution ist
auch wieder in einer neuen studie
unterschied ja definitiv also ich habe
mehr als zehn jahre angefangen mich
auseinandersetze mit sowie unsere
feministischen perspektive mit themen
rund um pornografie sexualität ändern
und habe nicht nur einigermaßen gefüllt
was günstig kommt wieder so
laut taxi und dann ist es überhaupt dazu
der feminismus wir sind auf die
beherrscht mit tusche und und ich glaube
dass hatte kontext fällig für andere
also das hat er so oft zeigt dass so
viele probleme auf das einfach so
persönlich ab da wurde sie nicht allzu
ernst genommen sind sagt dass das
strukturelle problem sind wo ja wo
christa sind es jetzt nur bis 2 manche
jetzt mit macht das zum allerersten mal
nicht vor live publikum so oder so zu
sagen willst du hin also bis zum roten
fahne irgendwo da hamann sowie ist das
geschlecht wie das vorhaben experimente
nicht vorstellig das jetzt an wie viele
haushalte wie der schweiz einzelhandel
und der gruppe von menschen wie ein teil
sind vor dem gleichzeitig ich finde es
hatte bis sehr aufregend jetzt habe ich
noch nie vorbereiten des kalibers tabu
greta über masturbation sicher ist aber
bis heute sprach situation und das neues
buch fällt das andere
du kannst nicht ein ganzes leben etwas
machen was du verstecken muss
die männer finde ich in kontakt bars ein
service ist 15 es gibt regelmäßige
kunden die dürfen auch mal länger
bleiben gerne hier auf dem strich platz
kann ich arbeiten wann ich will
das geld das ich verdiene gehört mir
selber
es sind porträts unterschiedlichster
frauen im buch ich bin sexarbeiterin
alle geschichten erzählen von deren
arbeitsbedingungen
menschen die kriminellen seiten des
sexgewerbe es kommen nur am rande vor
rebecca angelini eine der
herausgeberinnen des buchs plädiert für
einen anderen blick auf die arbeit von
prostituierten sex arbeit danke dann
einmal bilder im kopf
sexarbeit lässt ganz viele
unterschiedliche gefühle jusos gut denke
ich es wird der sexarbeiterin
hauptsächlich als opfer betrachtet also
als hilflose immigrantin wo nix los lied
schweiz grund und da aufbietet wird das
sind ja nicht sex arbeiterinnen sondern
das sind ja menschen da sind frauen
das sind mütter töchter mit einem job
als unterhalt bestritten wo ihre familie
unterstützt
oft wissen die unterstützten familien
nicht wie das geld erarbeitet wurde
nicht nur die partie ist auch die fotos
im buch erzählen von einsamkeit aber
auch von sehnsüchten zb vom großen
wunsch einer nigerianerin einen mann zu
finden der es wagt ganz normal mit ihr
öffentlichen café zu sitzen
[Musik]
einer der nicht seine frau anruft wenn
du dann eben liegst schatz wie geht es
dir
[Musik]
eine der porträtierten nennt sich lady
kate
die us-amerikanerin sagt sexarbeit sei
für sie eine berufung für die dunklen
seiten findet sie vor allem
umschreibungen es gibt gewalt drogen und
es ist schmutzig viele illegale sachen
passieren
das problem ist dass die dinge sehr
schnell eskalieren in diesem geschäft
als domina für sie ein privilegiertes
leben als die meisten des gewerbes sie
kämpft mit der herausgeberin des buches
dafür dass sex arbeit von behörden und
gesellschaft als arbeit anerkannt wird
ist auch das älteste gewerbe denke ich
also denke ich dass es nötig ist dass
wir als gesellschaft es stärker
akzeptieren und mehr verständnis dafür
haben in der schweiz ist sex arbeit seit
1942 legal fitz die fachstelle
frauenhandel und frauen migration
schätzt dass jährlich bis zu 20.000
personen im erotik gewerbe arbeiten
der jahresumsatz beträgt ungefähr eine
milliarde franken
ganz wichtig wäre wirklich dass frauen
und männer zu hause wo in der sexarbeit
aktiv sind uns alle keine das sexarbeit
abend ist vielleicht keine arbeit wie
die andere
das ist prekäre arbeit wie andere
arbeiter auf sexarbeiterinnen hand wenig
recht sie werden diskriminiert
arbeitsbedingungen sind oftmals break
her
von den sechs arbeiterinnen sind 75%
migrantinnen oft haben sie schlechte
deutschkenntnisse administratives können
sie häufig nicht korrekt erledigen
daraus entstehen schwierigkeiten das
verhältnis zu den behörden ist vielmals
angespannt
was mir gesehen die ihm behördliche
umgang mit sechs dabei die schippe dass
es sehr häufig in der behördliche logik
darum gott sechs kontrollieren
das wüsste wer schafft mit einem
aufenthaltstitel wirklich die daten
erfassen und dass ihr genau dahin gehend
argumentiert dass man mit m frauen
schützt und das ist problematisch weil
eigentlich ist desto mehr frauenrechte
und sie damit so mitgliedern der
gesellschaft auf augenhöhe zu machen
doch das größte dilemma ein leben in
aller heimlichkeit von dem nicht mal die
eigene familie weiß aufgrund
verdächtiger jährige eigentlich die
meisten sexarbeiterinnen das doppelte
also das heißt ich nicht am abend vor
ihrem arbeitsalltag erzählen wenn man
sich vorstellt mit befindet sich in
einem sorgerechtsstreit denn da kann man
so gar nicht darüber reden dass man
sechs arbeiterinnen ist und das ist sehr
belastend
in diesem buch hat vieles platz die
düstere seite des gewerbes
frauenschicksale aber auch die starken
selbstbewussten sexarbeiterinnen kommen
vor sie alle verdienen unseren respekt
[Musik]
halle jetzt aber noch einmal frische
luft in wenigen minuten gehts los mit
ihrer performance was willst du glaub
ich erreichen in der performance wasser
das ziel
ich habe super lieblingsmomente
performance- und ich hoffe das lied für
die heizungs netto etwa lieblings
momentan was sie zum lachen bringen wo
sie zum kritische diskussion anregen
oder wo sie inspirierte story
wir sind stabil wir sind nicht nur
dauert ewig in einem radiostudio sondern
sind auch live mit die bibi der
radioempfang erinnern und zwar in einer
wg in euro ersparnis aber die macht mit
vize wurde das ist kein tonaufnahmen sie
uns vielleicht wirklich stammen
vielleicht tut es mir peinlich oder
unangenehm sie ja befehligte bemüht und
das interessiert mich zum user finden
für mich war klar dass ich gezwungen
entweder ein nackt sie weiter so
[Musik]
wir werden nun gemeinsam meditieren und
empfehlen euch eure herzen zu öffnen und
eure schenkel zu spreizen und gemeinsam
zu masturbieren
aber natürlich kennt die nur zuhören
liegt nun beide hände auf euer herz und
richtet eure aufmerksamkeit gegen innen
spielt eine wärme hin euren mustin spürt
die wärme auf euren fußsohlen spürt die
wärme und das kribbeln wie es von der
innenseite eure schinkel ihre genitalien
erreicht und diese warm werden
die wärme steigt von eur zungenspitze in
eurem rahmen bleibt erhöhte tierleid
genießt also eine erektion oder genießt
den weichen und entspannten zustand
ihres geschlechtes
[Musik]
nun sucht euch einen anderen körperteil
aus vielleicht in der regel italien ja
gar nicht im finstern stelle die ihr
habt
[Musik]
peter sorg begeistert mit studien und
zum wohl miteinander
ich hasse ich noch genau interessant
gefunden dass man zwar die berühre
gekürzt aber es ist aber nicht macht
wieso die kontrast und dann ist fantasie
mir klar jetzt sehr froh dass velbert
rührige ständig ribery olic ja ich hatte
mir das zu intensiv conti weiter dass es
tatsächlich doch recht hat uns mit sorge
hat und als alle träume auf weiß gott
was für zieht ist wie im flug vergangen
es ist schnell ob sie wie wichtig mir
ist dass ich so im nun vergangen und
wahrscheinlich auch wieder das publikum
nicht im raum k
doch die will ich lesen sie die so einen
tiefschlaf ich bin also die sowie war
nicht ganz so dass mehr raum jetzt
wieder erwacht
[Musik]
um mehr leute die da zieht's andere
person wo sämtliche gramm zuvor schon
unter schlacht sprang
ein zerbrechliches wesen auf
gefährlicher mission 2014 im ukraine
konflikt als selbsternannte miss world
senkt madame nielsen liebeslieder an der
front sie will die menschen
zusammenbringen ist das provokativ es
ist die mutige aktion eines menschen der
nicht greifbar sein will
der in leben und werk gegen
zuschreibungen und eindeutigkeit
ankämpft ich bin eine öffnung ins
ungewisse
ich bin nicht etwas bestimmtes oder
jemand bestimmtes aus ihrer devise hat
man am liebsten das kunstwerk gemacht
dass ihr leben ist
nun ist sie in der schweiz hierzulande
seit ein paar jahren als
schriftstellerin bekannt in ihrer heimat
dänemark kennt man sich schon lange
bis vor einigen jahren als klaus beck
neeson als schillernder künstler auf
vielen bühnen in ständiger verwandlung
das leben als aufgabe so viele
daseinsformen wie möglich zu leben
der mensch und die mensch ist die
männchen ist ja ein wesen mit ein
endloses potenzial und das heißt auch
dass wir haben die möglichkeit jeden tag
anders zu wert nun anders zu handeln und
anders zusammen zu werden und nicht nur
automatisch immer wieder war nissen auf
kühler mission bei dieser wanderung
durch afghanistan ging es darum für
demokratie zu werben
als einziger westlicher zivilist typisch
europäisch in anzug und krawatte nur mit
einer weißen fahne des friedens die man
allerdings auch anders deuten konnte als
taliban flagge oder als zerstörte
taliban flagge beides nicht ungefährlich
[Musik]
man muss in jeder bewegung sein leben
aufs spiel setzen nicht als totes sucht
aber weil das leben nur lebendig wert
wenn wenn der tod auch möglich ist vor
zehn jahren inszenierte nielsen den tod
den tod ihrer identität als klaus beck
ließ ein siebentägiges sterbe lager mit
leichen zu der weg war frei für madame
ließen
seit 2013 legt sie als frau
als künstlerin und autorin die in ihren
texten die welt neu formulieren will
und dabei aus der riskant gelebten
künstler wie erschöpft zwei romane sind
erschienen
der endlose sommer und zuletzt das
monster ihre rauschhaften texte kreisen
um die frage was ist ein mensch was die
liebe und wie geht ein ideales leben
madame nielsen umarmt die welt das helle
und das dunkle darin und das meist in
endlos langen sätzen
ich versuche erzählung als musik zu
schreiben die sprache als mal gern die
lange sätze die sowie lasse würfe sind
und mit jedem lasso wurf muss sich die
ganze welt und alles möglich es
begreifen
nun bringt barzen bei ihrem
poetikvorlesungen im literaturhaus
zürich ihr ganzes dasein als gelebtes
kunstwerk auf den punkt das eine geht in
dem anderen über bei mir in meinem leben
und werk ist als übergang grauzone bild
verhandlung ständiges wandern und wandel
normal ich und mit sich selbst identisch
immer wieder sein eigener andere
vielleicht werde ich mal ein reiher
einer dieser merkwürdigen nervösen vögel
sagt madame hinzen
und so abwegig ist das vielleicht auch
gar nicht
[Musik]
hinter der die meisten fäustchen drach
charakterlich wunder wachsen in wald
gezogen wir können das yoga und doch
kann was er brauche das nur wieder neu
geführt werde ich das bedürfnis ja ich
finde das irgendwie lustig so die
kommission wie weiland sowie haben dass
sexualität in der pornografie gegenüber
will mehr also denn die war das war
balsam für unsere kultur stattfindet und
wo gern sex hat nicht so ernst oder so
offen ausspricht und das sind zur frage
wo mich einfach auf ihre theorien mega
interessiert oder philosophie soeben
ihre künstlerische perspektiven ihres
medium was bedeutet das bedeutet für
mich hat das viel mit selbstbestimmung
store weiß ich was ich will und was ich
nicht will und kann ich das
kommunizieren und auch alle anderen
was bedeutet das für die gesellschaft so
eigentlich immer noch sehr fest die
konventionen drin ist sind wir überhaupt
bereit für das können wir sie überhaupt
so lange aber das glaube ich erst wenn
ich so dankbar wenn ich angefangen haben
nicht so intensiv mit den themen
sexualität auseinandersetzen perspektive
ist es noch so ist sie auch so anders
sind unvorstellbar dass ein kulturplatz
handgemachte übrigen asiatischen oder
dass mir für ponys
das filmkunstfest ich habe mich geändert
haben ich finde ich mir darüber kommen
zum affen nicht möglich sie und das hat
sich innerhalb von denen acht jahre
jetzt vom festival zum beispiel extrem
stark verändert vor dem er glaube ja
müssen total blöd dass und die hand
darauf wieder bis sie frei
das gefühl die nutzer und zelebriert um
die ganzen ideen und zu dir die freiheit
alter wo man hin will ich glaube dass
ich meckere verabschieden das richtige
schnell wieder für andere und für mich
geschaut grund wir sondern die bietenden
freiraum wo man sachen ausprobieren wo
man dann je nachdem auch wieder
gesellschaftliche oder politische
strukturen zu spielen
übermorgen startet das festival polizei
und sie sicher wäre die letzte station
sich wer ganz viel erfolgt heute teufel
in dem extrakt natalia schmidt das ist
eine begegnung die mir bleiben wir wie
wichtig dass es botschafterinnen gibt
für die weibliche selbstermächtigung
umso irritierender ist es nach dieser
begegnung voller lust sich in erinnerung
zu rufen wie viele frauen gewalt erleben
heute ist der internationale tag gegen
gewalt an frauen laut einer studie von
amnesty international hat jede fünfte
frau in der schweiz schon sexuelle
übergriffe erlebt wir stellen ihnen
jetzt zwei künstlerinnen vor die dagegen
ein zeichen setzen
das schild symbol des schutzes der
verteidigung blutrote farbe auf weißem
hemd gewalt das wissen diese beiden
frauen hinterlässt narben
doch manchmal kann kunst heilen helfen
größten
magath selbst dramatische
gewalterfahrungen gemacht diese aber
jahrelangen sich verschlossen
ich war wirklich in einem punkt in
meinem leben wo ich dachte entweder mag
ich mache ich diese deckel auf und lasse
das alles raus weil das zerstört mich
innerlich oder ich springe aus dem glück
es verlangte von mir mut aber es hat
sich doch nur noch meine trophäen auch
der aufwand
die künstlerin hat während zehn jahren
die vielen unsichtbaren folgen
psychischer gewalt erforscht
ja sie ziert
und mit diesem wissen an den reigen an
schutzschildern geschaffen die je eine
facette von gewalt und machtmissbrauch
sichtbar und greifbar machen sollen nur
ex arbeiten tragen erschreckende titel
wie mein vater liebt mich und würde mir
nie etwas böses antun so hier
hundertfach geschrieben ein mantra des
schreckens oder erotik des gehirns ein
schild das das destruktive muster bahnen
soll in dem manche als kind missbrauchte
frau steckt wenn sie sich immer wieder
gewalttätige partner sucht dieser frauen
durch diesen missbrauch haben gelernt
mit sexueller erregung auf bedrohliche
situationen zu reagieren und bis diese
frauen das nicht verstehen können sie
oft aus diesem teufelskreis nicht raus
aufbrechen raus aus dem opferdasein mit
vorträgen und workshops ermutigt nord
frauen sich zu befreien
selbstheilungskräfte zu aktivieren dies
ist ebenso ein zentrales anliegen von
franziska gräber die künstlerin ist auch
psychotherapeutin und ehemalige leiterin
einer krisen interventionsstelle gegen
häusliche gewalt
ich denke ein haus in dem eine frau
nicht sicher ist ist kein zuhause
erhoben
psychotherapeutin bin ich an meiner
projekts kann diese unterstanden und
haben die geschichte ist eine insellage
als künstlerin habe ich jetzt plötzlich
möglichkeit für mich gefunden die beiden
seiten von mir miteinander verbinden
gräber sammelt geschichten von frauen
aus der ganzen welt in acht ländern auch
in der schweiz hat sie ihr
feministisches kunstprojekt bremen in
the dark schon umgesetzt und das soll
erst der anfang sein
oli partizipieren der länder und
organisationen haben genau diese vorgabe
und dir ist eigentlich minimal
es heißt
die pvs freudig stück zur sie während
dem skipass begleiten lasse alles
schrieb aber es gibt keine zensur
ihre erlebnisse wünsche aber auch ihre
forderungen halten die frauen auf den
händen fest
die nie wieder nie wieder schlägst du
mich nie wieder box du mich nie wieder
lässt du mich nicht schlafen nie wieder
zuerst du mich aus dem kinderzimmer
hinaus um mit mir zu reden was sie unter
erfahrungen dann führe ich sehr
unterschiedlich das können der vorige
verwaltung diskriminierung am eigenen
körper betreiberfamilie sie das könnte
aber vor strukturelle konsequenzen
gräber fügt diese hunderten von
schilderungen schließlich zusammen zu
einer installation eine art textile
kakophonie des widerstandes aus dem
privaten werden die statements an die
öffentlichkeit gehievt ans licht
gebracht
sich interessant dass eine sehr viel
über frauen dann oder alles rund ums
drucken erfreut dass sie wirklich also
meine ort und spuren hinterlasse ihre
stimmen gesehen und gehört werden
ich habe diese bluse beschrieben ohne
gezwungen zu werden
ich bin eine prostituierte verdiene
meinen lebensunterhalt mit sex meine
kinder gehen jeden tag zur schule und
haben genug zu essen
[Musik]
frauen die gewalterfahrungen in sich
tragen sollen sich nicht einsam damit
fühlen
kunst kann genau dieses leiden und diese
erfahrenen greifbar machen
baggerfahrer ist das thema von 160 wege
ist für mich keine option
[Musik]
kulturplatz künstlerinnen und künstlern
in corona zeiten unterstützung anbieten
wir haben vor zwei wochen einen aufruf
gemacht und uns entscheiden welche der
vielzähligen projekte von uns
unterstützt werden haben wir eine
unabhängige jury aufgeboten darunter
pedro lenz oder der flasche ja und die
qual der wahl dieser jury
das sind sie bei uns auf dem motto platz
nächsten mittwoch gleich jetzt gehts
weiter mit dem report der markt kommen
sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
tourismus
[Musik]